to everybody collectively lose their
[__] minds when he got their KO I
want to know his entire thought process
as he's seeing I'm all of it I'm
imagining he sees perdeda loading up the
left again because padetta lands a big
left but he blocks it and then he sees
him dipping to load it again and then it
is just lightning fast what does that
feel what is the liberation of slaying
the dragon of knowing you could beat a
guy he's beating you three times he's
taken everything and then you've finally
beat him an in convincing fashion he
can't say a single thing he's
unconscious knocked out what he did to
you you just did to him when you decide
to exchange with somebody in that moment
that's an all-in hand in poker because
if you get caught someone bigger than
you is stronger than you and keep in
mind he's not imagining it's over yeah
he's felt it be over yeah a bravery of
sitting there in that moment going this
is a 50 50. either I'm gonna hit him and
it's and it's lights out or he's gonna
hit me and it's lights out again and he
just decides to do it I'm prepared to
die and I've been prepared to die